[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
what is up what is good how you living
how you feeling how you doing the guy
to my left is connor rogers the hair is
flowing and the draft takes are going to
be great uh this is a sad day
but it's an exciting day it's our last
live thursday show because the nfl draft
is a week away counter rogers the
national holiday has arrived
we will have one more show connor sunday
it's gonna be our mock draft special
it's gonna be in the app as well 11
o'clock
we want to welcome in everybody on
twitter everybody on youtube and of
course
everybody in the br app i will be
monitoring your comments and seeing
which ones
are really good connor today it is
instant
impact prospects i hear we have two for
each position what's the idea here what
are we looking for
well we got to state the obvious left go
a lot of times the best players in the
draft are the ones that should make the
instant impact
so the first name you're going to hear
at every position group is probably a
first round player that you've heard a
lot of but
what we're going to spend a lot of time
is the other guy
listed maybe somebody that's the not so
obvious maybe someone that's going in
the second third or fourth round that
could be a day one starter that could
quietly be
a rookie of the year contender so
there's gonna be new names on this show
that we're excited to reveal today
think about it it's not just you know
the top running back it's also james
robinson who goes to the jaguars
it's not just justin jefferson it's
chase claypool who goes
around later so we'll give you the way i
look at it is
the early round rookies that could win
rookie of the year
and the one that can shock them so we'll
go through that as
always uh we appreciate the comments
we'll read as many as we can
jj i'm feeling real confident mac jones
is going at three i just wanted you to
know that
just that bet you're gonna owe me twenty
dollars pretty pumped about that
draft night next thursday connor me
a kid to leave sitting on the desk it is
going to be an
absolute blast when a when a quarterback
gets drafted
we call up our g3 when a wide receiver
gets drafted
we call up reggie wayne somebody in the
trenches the amazing cam jordan
we have a laundry list of guests that
are going to be
joining us and bringing insight and also
if you have a crazy reaction to a draft
pick so record yourself when your team
is up
submit it to the nfl draft community and
we will get you
swags and be our gridiron swag let's get
down
to the show and as the bottom of the
screen says news and rumors
devonta smith weighs in at 166
at six feet connor your reaction
well you know obviously he probably
wanted to keep this under wraps a little
bit and chose not to weigh in at his pro
day and it's all
anyone ever asked and then obviously
there are medical checks in indianapolis
this year still and the weight gets
out that he's 166 left go and it changes
nothing for me
with devante smith i still have him 10th
overall i think
this is somebody that obviously won the
heisman
but dominated the sec you got to be
pretty strong to do that with devante
smith you have to ask yourself
does the weight ever impact him on film
is he getting
jammed at the line of scrimmage and
getting thrown to the sideline is he
you know too easy to tackle or anything
like that does he play
small none of those things so i'm not
bothered by this
but i do wonder if nfl teams overthink
this my gut instinct is
they won't if devonte smith starts the
slide and we talked about the over under
of 11 and a half so i thought he's going
in the top 11 picks
if he makes it past 11 and starts to get
closer to 15
somebody will probably trade up and that
person is very smart so
it doesn't really impact me from the
people i've talked to they don't really
seem very concerned about it because
he's such a good route runner
he's great in contested catch situations
he's not somebody that's banged up all
the time because of this weight or
anything like that so
it's a juicy story line for a lot of
people we don't get 166 pound receivers
that are
projected top 15 picks in many drafts
but sometimes there's outliers left go
and you don't want to make a habit of
betting on them but this is one that you
bet on
also when this becomes your job
and you are eating and under a
nutritional guideline and in the weight
room all the time and there are no
classes and there is no train
it's just this i would be surprised if
he didn't add some weight
it's just a fact of playing in the nfl
i've interviewed a ton of rookies and
then i meet them five years later
and they don't even look the same
because they become a man
so let's also realize that he's going to
get up to what 170 180 it's definitely
possible
we talk a lot we talked on monday on the
left go show misinformation season is
here
a lot of people want to trade down
connor do you think that
how many of the trade down opportunities
will really present themselves
i mean once the quarterbacks are gone
you don't see a lot of trade downs the
one that i do have my eye on and i think
i've told you this before left go is
what happens if pene sewell starts the
slide right there's a lot of rumors
around the bengals at five that they'll
take jamar chase i think it's pretty
close it'll be sewell or chase
and then you start to wonder you know is
miami going to take one of these wide
receivers for tua does rashaan slater go
before sewell the something that
a lot of people have spoken to think
could happen so if sewell starts the
slide you have teams like
the lions that have a lot of work to do
the panthers
they have a lot of work to do on their
roster as well relatively new regimes
a new gm for the lions a new gm of
course for the panthers and a coach
that's only been there for a year
those are the teams that realistically
could trade out because the fifth
quarterback could fall there sewell
could fall there
a wide receiver that teams really like
maybe even kyle pitts
but these rumors of every team outside
the top 15
trying to move down i know chris ballard
would love to do it every single year
there's got to be somebody that teams
want to come up for and often
that is not the case that makes sense so
penny sewell rashaan slater the two big
offensive lineman the quarterbacks
and then after that it's something we
talked about you don't have that upper
tier corner that upper tier pass rusher
and so really who's trading up who is
going to be your partner something to
think about
as you read all of these reports and
blogs over the next week
okay let's get into it instant impact
prospects
these are guys that conor believes
depending on the situation
could come in right away and have an
impact on the nfl we're only doing
one quarterback and so of trevor
lawrence zach wilson mack jones justin
fields trey lance
who's the one that you think comes in
right away and has an instant impact
i hate to do the most obvious one but
it's the number one overall pick and
that's trevor lawrence right we know
he's gonna be a week one starter
we know this team is gonna do everything
they can to build around him
we saw him come in as a true freshman
and win games at clemson and win with
his legs and win with his arm
and often that is the best uh variable
for rookie quarterbacks to have success
and we know justin fields and trey lance
they're guys that can run as well you'd
like to see
fields run even more than he already
does lance we don't know if he's going
to start coming out of the fcs and
not playing this year because his season
was moved to the spring so
trevor lawrence is the guy that you sit
there and go well we know he's gonna
play right away
we know he's got the athleticism to pick
up yards we know he's got
really good arm strength and
intermediate accuracy has gotten better
year after year
he's played against a high level of
competition in a very very big stage on
the college football platform so
trevor lawrence is the one that comes in
and probably has a pretty good amount of
success
as a rookie quarterback will be perfect
at times no he's going to throw his
interceptions
he's coming out of a very college
offense right a lot of screens a lot of
quick throws along the lines of that
but trevor lawrence should have a very
very big impact well luckily he's going
to a team that will likely be running a
lot of college schemes led by urban
meyer down there in jacksonville also
jacksonville
i mentioned james robinson before all
those years where that offensive line
was sort of rebuilding
suddenly it's a little bit more stable
than i think people realize
and they do have some wide receiver
weapons around him
trevor lawrence should be interesting i
also think tennessee may take a step
back this year
i think houston is an absolute mess so i
do think it's an
easier division than if you were to go
to the afc east
like possibly zack wilson where you're
playing the bills
patriots and dolphins who all look to be
ready to roll let's get an app comment
here
from parker larson one what are the
chances of
six quarterbacks going in the first
round i named the other five
connor so i guess the question is what
are the chances give me a percentage
and who do you believe that sixth would
be if it did happen
i'll say five percent maybe there is
some very very small chance and i think
it would be a tree a team trading back
in i know everybody likes to use the
saints i i've heard
that is not the direction they're
expected to go in the first round we'll
see how that plays out
so you have the davis mills the kellen
mons and the kyle trask of the world
and just the way you hear me say those
names left go i don't think it's
happening
i think those guys will be day two
selections i don't even think they'll be
you know come off the board at 33 34 for
teams trading up
i know a lot of people like to look at
it and go the fifth year option or
they're just not talented enough players
to bet the house on in the first round
right now davis mill started 11 games 11
games
i don't see it so five percent maybe we
get that draft knight surprise
it's happened before but i don't see it
happening
all right let's go to instant impact
running back and now we are going to do
two
someone that could go in the first round
and someone that could go later
and so i think when we talk about first
rounders it's really gonna either going
to be travis etienne
or naji harris who do you think is that
instant impact of the early selections
i think it's naji harris and the reason
being and this is gonna be the case for
the name i'm gonna go on about later the
day two name
is nfl coaches will put a rookie running
back on the field
if they're ready in pass protection and
i see that with naji harris he really
excels at all three phases of the
running back position and that's
obviously as a runner
but as a pass catcher and a pass
protector and that's why i think he's
going to go in the first round lefko
which
we don't always get that with running
backs there's no lock for one in round
one every single year
but i think an nfl coach will be ready
to put him on the field
i think he's gonna go to a landing spot
where he gets an insane
workload you look at the steelers you
look at the dolphins you look at teams
along the lines of that
that just makes a lot of sense that he's
your three down runner
and he's been running over defenders and
away from defenders in the sec for
years where i don't want to say it's not
going to be
that much different but i remember
interviewing leonard fournette on stick
to football many years ago i think he
was a rookie at the time and i said to
him i said man what's this adjustment
been like you've been in the league for
a couple months
he's like man coming out of the sec
because it's not that
different and i think naji harris is
built the same mentally where it won't
really faze him as much so
naji harris big instant impact could
even be one of those round one round two
fantasy picks with the workload he's
expected to get as a rookie
of course depending on the landing spot
but he'll be exciting to watch right
away
all right i want to dive into naji and
we're going to go into in a second but
first i am going to need
your later round impact player so maybe
someone that doesn't go in the first
round
that could come out of nowhere like a
james robinson and challenge naji as the
best
rookie running back next year it'll be
javonte williams i think the reason
being he
he creates his own yards he's incredible
at forcing miss tackles he loves
loves blocking in the backfield loves
protecting his quarterback
really incredible character makeup you
know valedictorian
coming out of high school just a
brilliant guy a really successful player
so i think you look at him he's probably
going to go late in the second round
i compared him to chris carson just a
bowling ball that can run right through
you
good enough burst not to break away like
etn but he's just going to come in ready
to go and he's got experience in a ski
and a
zone heavy scheme but you know he can
excel as a man runner i'm laughing at
tacklers bouncing off of him
because it's going to look like this in
the nfl he's just so good at creating
his own yards
like you said chris carson connor his
picture he looks like chris carson
i'm telling you it's the comp for him
for me and people react a weird way to
that when i say it they're like chris
carson that's underwhelming i'm like
chris carson's quietly been
one of the better running backs in the
nfl lately so
he's just he's pro ready lefko he he
runs uh like a
grown man strength in his running style
like i said coaches will just
love that he really owns up to being a
really reliable pass protector
and he's ready for a big workload so you
know you look at the jets if they trade
out of 34 maybe even take him at 34 oh
that would be a surprise
the falcons are another team that needs
a running back and could have a big
workload
i mentioned the dolphins and steelers if
they don't take naji harris or etn in
round one
maybe they look at javonte williams in
round two so
like naji big workload huge rookie
impact
all right so let me take back what i
said i said that was a late rounder
that's definitely one of those first
second rounders so that's not the first
running back off the board
because javonte williams is not lasting
to the third or fourth round after what
i saw
and after what everybody in the comments
section saw javonte williams right there
man that was i think about like a nick
chubb
who didn't go right in the first round
but in the second round you're like oh
he was right up there with everybody
else there out of georgia
okay you mentioned naji harris and you
mentioned the steelers
there's something about the last name
harris running for the steelers that got
me very excited
and so i want to build a dream draft for
the steelers if they were to go naji
at 24 who do they take at two and three
in their second and third round picks
to make it a dream draft for the
steelers
yeah i think if they're gonna take a
running back in round one which is a
risk for any team and definitely a bold
move they still have significant needs
at cornerback and offensive lines so
round two
i look at ahsante samuel jr right get
yourself a corner
uh that sure he's a little undersized
but very very feisty
good click and close good speed good
agility
i think even at that size he can play
man coverage just because he could stay
in the hip pocket
of wide receivers and i look at the
steelers they they cut stephen nelson
they're a little thin at corner right
now you can get ahsante samuel jr in
round two
you got yourself a starter and i think
that's something to be really really
excited about so they're it's gonna be
interesting how they view the round the
run
on corners in round one one of the top
four might not be there when they pick
in round one so you got naji harris you
got asante samuel
like i said they still got needs on the
offensive line
and this is a deep offensive line class
that you can get starters in round three
so if you're ready for this name let go
stone forsythe from florida he is a
gigantic offensive tackle he's six foot
nine
really reliable in pass protection one
of those players that just hard to get
around him or get through when you're
rushing the passer incredible length
but really good balance at that size
most offensive tackles that are above
six foot
six six foot seven you always question
how their feet and overall balance and
ability to mirror is gonna be
there's no concerns there for him he
might not make it to round three with
the kind of rise he's had and i know
it's hard to be
a driving run blocker at that height it
really is hard to get leverage so
he's gonna have a little bit of work to
do there but he's one of the most
underrated offensive lineman in this
class and it would be a huge get for the
steelers in round three
steelers used to those big offensive
linemen alejandro villanueva one of
those six
eight six nine guys he is now often free
agency you're right you take a look at
that steelers offensive line
they have a lot of new names for a unit
that has been pretty solid for the last
five
six years we have an app comment connor
this one is from
ravage savage 44 which is
one of the better app names i've heard
is jamar
chased to the bengals the closest thing
to a lock this has been the last
week or two jamar chase being penciled
in an all mock drafts there at number
five to the bengals
do you think it's a lock early on this
was penny sewell
this was rashawn slater are you willing
right now
what percentage i want to hear your lock
percentage
not a luck i'm going to put it at 50
right now and i might even up that to
i'll say 60
so not a luck but you feel good about it
number one you have the most important
voice in the room joe burrow
advocating to select jamar chase number
two he's one of the best wide receiver
prospects we've seen in the last five
years just no brainer in terms of that
now what you wonder is
would they rather take penne sewell
after what happened to joe burrow last
year is it going to be a reactionary
selection in that case
then my question is like jonah williams
is a serviceable left tackle right now
so is penne going to play on the right
side
is he gonna play guard are you gonna
move jonah
that's the questions i have with
offensive line even the same questions
that they took rashaan slater so
60 for jamar chase that's the pick that
i think
is happening but it's not a luck right
now there are a lot of people even the
dolphins i think are sitting there
wondering after moving back to six i
know
they would probably love to have jamar
chase they're probably sitting there
going
hey we might not be able to get him now
because he's this kind of dominant
player i mean you see him against diggs
there who's starting in the nfl now
he bodies nfl level defenders and he was
19 years old in this he's great after
the catch
he's only getting stronger he ran really
really well
and we know what the jamar chase and joe
burrow connection can do we've already
seen it
for an undefeated national title run
what would it do in the nfl i think it'd
be really special
it sounds like you want to make him your
early round instant impact
guy yeah i mean just a no-brainer
because
even when he's not open he's open let's
go you throw up the ball to him and he
makes
so jamar chase uh just a no-brainer
instant impact like i said he's got a
lot of juice after the catch
very very confident he can run by nfl
corners because we've already really
seen him do it
and i think that he comes into an
offense that quite frankly
has some good skill talent where you're
not just going to sell out to stop him
so
jamar chase set up for a huge amount of
targets from a quarterback that just
loves the guy
big time instant impact uh got a comment
in the app pat chamberlain are those ice
cream cones on your shirt lefko i'm
trying to figure out and it's been
killing me
yes why because the nfl draft is a treat
conor that was your instant impact early
what about a guy that's
that could go either later in the first
round second round
uh who could be another impact guy at
wide receiver not named jamar chase so
he never gets mentioned with jamar chase
devonte smith jayla model anyone like
that but rashad bateman
is much closer to that crop of wide
receivers
than people think and rashad bateman is
a player that does
all the right things that translate
early on in the nfl releases off the
line of scrimmage route running
catching the ball in traffic playing
above the rim running hard after the
catch
and just winning at all levels of the
field you see those
light feet i mean they have corners
frozen and he can track the football
the deep ball he's fearless player i
look at the teams that make so much
sense for him left go
your eagles if they trade it out or i
don't even knock the pick if they took
him there although i don't think that's
gonna happen
the packers at the end of round one
maybe finally get that other receiver
for aaron rodgers
and then the ravens they couldn't get a
top flight wide receiver to sign there
this offseason
but he's their kind of guy a physical
player reminds me a little of keenan
allen a little of stevie johnson that
unorthodox footwork at the line of
scrimmage that kind of scrambles corners
so
rashad bateman is an underrated player
have not seen him get a lot of round one
love
think he's very very worthy of a round
one selection baltimore picking at 27
green bay picking at 29
it does make sense there at the end of
the first round if they were looking
for an explosive player at the wide
receiver position
just to add a little bit bateman four
for one four four one
forty and the longest arms of almost any
wide receiver other than draft other
than collins out of michigan with
33-inch arms so he's got
pretty nice wingspan and at 21 years old
what'd you say
those are offensive tack alarms that's
the threshold for an offensive tackle 33
inches
pretty unbelievable okay we have an app
comment here from
sony michelle juice will kyle pitts
be the best tight end in the nfl
in five years so in five years travis
kelsey's in his thirties
um you know darren waller's in his
thirties what do you think connor
george yeah i mean by the ball he should
be with the expectations i believe
kittle should be 32 kelsey will be 36
and i want to say waller will be he'll
definitely be in his 30s as well so
by default he should be now what i'll
say lefko
you never want to bet the house on round
one tight ends the
last decade of round one tight ends has
been uh
very very up and down to say the least
but i like kyle pitts a lot
in terms of production he'll he should
be a really really good wide receiver
we've said it before don't think he'll
ever be the blocker that kittle or
kelsey necessarily are
but an all-world ceiling as a wide
receiver and we know how it goes left
though the guys that produce the fantasy
points
especially at odd positions like tight
end always get the most love
so i think kyle pitts is in he's on a
good track to at least be in contention
for that role
all right so he's obviously your instant
impact tight end we talked about this on
monday
it's him and then a huge drop off after
that drop
off who was a tight end that could have
an instant impact next year depending on
which team he goes to
it's tommy tremble from notre dame and
that's a name
that this is a bad tight end class it
unsurprisingly is not getting a ton of
love
but tremble does a lot of things that
fit in the nfl you see his ability to
move on the outside run game and get out
in front and block
this team did not use him as a receiver
but he tested as a high profile athlete
let go he's got
good size good move and ability he loves
to block
and it's not just wide receivers he can
get out and set the edge against
linebackers so
sure he might not be in your daily
fantasy lineup from week one
but can he get on the field in a lot of
these outside zone running games
and make a huge difference as a runner i
know the titans have been doing a lot of
work on
tight ends after they lost jonnu smith
and people look at johnny smith and they
think athletic pass catcher
he does a lot of nice things in the run
game for derrick henry as well so i look
at tremble who's been regarded as a
round three
round four prospect i think he's going
round two i look at the seahawks and
titans and just think that's such an
ideal fit for him
i mean you're seeing it right here he
lines up in the backfield he's more of
an hvac
you you know kyle juice check really
well from the 49ers
that's how notre dame kind of used this
guy and there's a big time place
for that in the nfl right now the demand
outweighs the supply of players like
this so tommy tremble is someone that
really really excited me on film the
athletic profile
checked out from his pro day very
impressive
instant impact blocker and i think he's
got a lot left in the tank to grow as a
pass catcher
6'3 241 around a 4-6-3-40 with a 1-5-6
split uh 78 and a half inch wingspan and
he's only 20 years old right now
to me listening to you talk it's almost
like bizarro kyle pitts
where the dude loves blocking and and
you go oh
maybe we can get some passing game out
of them a little bit later but
everything you show there
there's a lot of value of that in the
nfl a lot of value in that in the nfl
there's so much value in it because
there's a ton of teams that use guys
like this now the 49ers the titans green
bay
the new york jets with their new staff
are going to look for a player like this
and
once again now that they have arthur
smith
they're probably running like this too
that is a
a bad omission from me the falcons are
the perfect team in this situation and
they're such a perfect team for tight
end
they might sit tight and take kyle pitts
at four but if they don't
get bizarro tied kyle pitts and tommy
tremble
i like bizarro kyle pitts okay instant
impact
offensive line and i noticed here from
the notes
that you're not going slater and you're
not going penny sewell
and i get excited about this because now
i really get to learn so who are we
starting with as an instant impact guy
here
yeah i got tired when i was filling out
this rundown let go of giving you the
blue chip players after blue chip
players so
i start with tevin jenkins who i think
has climbed into round one he can go as
early
as 17 to the vegas raiders he's played
both spots for this offensive line you
see him at right tackle
he might be the best at finishing blocks
in the entire draft remember all the
highlights of makai bechten last year
tevin jenkins must have watched those
and said hey i want to replicate this i
want to be this guy
he can climb to the second level climb
to linebackers
and put them in the dirt he's just he
moves so well for that size he actually
reminds me of taylor luon left go he's
got that
really really upright sturdy frame long
arms
so powerful and he finishes blocks and
he's so athletic that
he's someone that really excites me in
this offensive line class if we walked
out of this draft in three years from
now we're like oh tevin jenkins is the
pro bowler of the offensive lineman
i wouldn't be shocked and i think teams
love that they could plug and play him
on the right side from day one
where he's gonna go somewhere in that
famous run i keep talking to you about
it starts at 17
with the raiders and ends at 24 with the
steelers where it could just be
offensive line mania so tevin jenkins
instant impact player has really
improved in pass pro
and he is just a mauler that does the
dirty work in the run game for his guys
so
it blocked for a good one in shuba
hubbard as well kevin jenkins
instant impact player once thought of as
a nice day two offensive tackle
a lock for round one right now brian
3000 says most violent man
in football my rule i like angry
offensive linemen
because it's easy to calm them down as
they get older but it's harder to get
them
angry if they just don't have it in them
and you can act like oh that's too rough
for our sport
they're offensive linemen they're
banging into people 50 times a game
i won the name of mean streak and look
at his picture he took my offensive
lineman pr
wear glasses people will think you're
smarter than you actually are
and if you are smart perfect uh
give me another guy offensive lineman i
was looking at the br gridiron page
and i noticed all of the outfits of
lyman that have come out of oklahoma
holy crap it is incredible i see by your
list
there we could be adding another name to
this list
yeah and crete humphrey has been there
for quite some time that he's played
with some of them already so creed
humphrey
center slash guard prospect i think he
comes in and plays center from day one
and he tested as
one of the best interior offensive line
athletes at this position that we have
ever seen and i think you watch the film
and he's somebody that once again like
tevin jenkins moves really well
great anchor in the middle so smart he's
played with a ton of nfl quarterbacks
already and this year he played for a
future one
in spencer rattler so creed humphrey has
about a million snaps of experience from
playing at oklahoma
that he comes in and he's pro ready he
can help out a young quarterback even as
a rookie
calling out linebacker helping mexico
line of scrimmage
really really nasty at the goal line for
you know
the offense to finish drive so creed
humphrey is someone that
never really gives up a sack never loses
in pass protection
does a really nice job in the run game
the center position
doesn't really get valued in round one
as much as we once thought i know we've
had you know the garrett bradberries of
the world and guys like that
but i think creed humphrey is somebody
that goes at the top of round two
and really has a long nfl career and
also can play for you for day one so
you know and i compared him to frank
ragno somebody who's had a ton of
success for the lions so far so
a no-brainer player comparison a tough
guy in the middle
uh jj is saying i want creed humphrey to
the 49ers
uh legendary name nene saying creed the
man's name
says it all creed humphrey is
that's a top tier name as well we got a
lot of good names tommy
so good i love this and and
you see that that interior offensive
line
i know that the chiefs just signed toony
uh but they could always use more
you mentioned the raiders already but
just to give people the context of that
run you were talking about for offensive
lineman in the first round
because this is a run that will happen
round after round
17 is the raiders 18 is the dolphins
19 is washington 20 is chicago
21 is indy who has lost some offensive
lineman this year
22 is tennessee who went through a lot
of injuries on their o-line last season
and then 23 as the jets and 24 is
pittsburgh that's the run
connor's been talking about you ready to
make the defense
yeah let's move to defense it's we'll
have plenty of time to talk about the
offensive line in the mock draft
okay app comment jwill101
how big of a risk is jalen phillips
medical history
give me a little bit of background about
where he could go
and the medical history and how that
could impact it
so i talked to a lot of people this
weekend you know scouts coaches that
have been doing these evals and
everybody's very comfortable with jalen
phillips in round one if you go back to
the first draft crash course he was
somebody that
was a very interesting player a
polarizing player because he has round
one talent really top 20 talent
the most talented pass rusher in the
entire draft
but an interesting history he's somebody
that was a
elite recruit right expected to be the
next miles garrett and goes to ucla gets
on the field as a freshman
is pretty productive but has plenty of
injury problems
and with his concussions was actually
forced to medically retire
takes a little time away from the game
transfers to miami
gets his body right for a year shows up
for 2020
ready to go him and quincy roche on that
offen on that defensive line gregory
russo opts out
there's an opportunity for him he's
beating double teams
he's a gigantic guy that can bend around
the corner
outside speed rush inside swim move
it really good against the run plays
hard plays with energy
so i asked teams i said you know our
team's okay with him medically now are
you guys okay with the medically
everyone seems to be okay you know the
question is can you get him to that
elite level we know all the traits are
there we know the flashes are there
so jalen phillips is going round one the
injury history is fascinating
and it can always work against you you
never know how violent game of football
is gonna go for anybody but jalen
phillips will hear his name called on
night one and he could be the best pass
rusher to come out of this draft
maybe i'm curious who your comp is maybe
it's because you said ucla and he
and how long he is but i thought of
cassius marsh
just when he first came out and sort of
his athletic profile who did you have as
your cop
yeah i haven't ziggy anza right just an
absolute freak
on the outside explosive uh long
not a lot of guys that are six foot five
260 can turn like that
and i know ziggy has had monster years i
know he's had
down years and the only reason he's had
his down years couldn't stay healthy so
ziggy's a great athlete a really good
player jalen just reminds me so much of
him with all those raw traits
all right so jalen phillips will be the
one that conor believes could have an
instant impact right away you mentioned
rousseau uh we know the guy there at
georgia you love as well but go a little
bit
later who's someone that might not crack
the first round that you think could
have an instant impact in year one
peyton turner from houston he's edge
number five for me in this draft and
actually found him from watching zach
wilson's film back in november and you
say who is this gigantic edge rusher
with good speed
great hustle against the run another big
guy that can turn the corner he can play
small when he needs to he can collapse
the pocket
that hit is just ridiculous with the
strip sack he reminds me of frank clark
lefko
somebody that is a really really big guy
that knows how to win the corner and a
lot of hustle in peyton turner's game he
knows how to
get to the run from the back side he
runs down the field
you could even drop them in coverage
with those long arms to disrupt passing
lanes
i saw inside counter moves payne turner
excites me i look at the giants look at
the vikings i look at the colts
jalen phillips if you want him in round
one makes a lot of sense
payton turner in round two or round
three probably round two
with the type of player and type of film
he has even with an injury history
is your discount jalen phillips i guess
we can say so these two guys
if either of them came in and had eight
to ten sacks from day one
just wouldn't be shocked at all just to
give people an
idea of how big this man is he is 6'5
270
which is the perfect weight and height
to man the edge and his arms
are 35 inches like that
punch is absurd his hands are 10 and a
quarter
like this is a monster of a human being
here connor peyton turner
yeah he's gigantic and the great thing
is with a player like that you
ask can they play you know a more
finesse brand when rushing the passer
he can but can he also play to his size
he can so peyton turner is somebody that
everyone should be excited about because
he's not this raw random guy coming out
of houston the film is really really
good
he got significantly better in 2020
he's a great athlete great size a
non-stop
motor and you see him going and going
and going he's an exciting player
okay cornerbacks i see that your instant
impact guys are two of the top guys in
the draft
so i i want to hear uh the
the players where you think they can go
and do you think that they're going to
really
turn it on the first year who do you
want to start with
yeah let's start with patrick certain in
a second right who reminds me of xavier
rhodes a big
long press corner that can really
disrupt routes at the line of scrimmage
ton of play experience against top
competition
can turn his hips can run downfield high
point the football
everybody says the cowboys at 10. it
feels like one of those things where
when it happens you just shrug and go
well we've heard this for three months
now
the cowboys can surprise you sometimes
but i think that's an area
a play where he a team where he comes in
and just starts right away and i think
wherever he goes he's gonna start right
away there's just not a lot of corners
that are built like this that have this
kind of length that
love to come downhill you see it against
the screen but he also does it against
the run so
certain you know the last name lives and
breeds football he has his whole life
plug and play corner a tough phrase to
say there's not a lot of corners that
are plug and play
he might not have the upside of the next
guy who is jc
horn who is another press corner who
gets a little grabby
but a really really good athlete before
we even you know found out he was going
to be our co-host for the draft i said
that's a keep to leave somebody that
wants to be in your ear
all day and says you're not going
anywhere i'm staying in that hip pocket
when the ball gets here i'm swatting it
away and i'm reminding you that it's
going to be
a long long day of this so jc horn
as well in play for dallas at 10 when
you look at it
the browns need a corner don't think
either of these guys
make it to them i know you know there's
a lot of teams that need corners that
don't even have the necessary capital to
get these guys they're going to be
very high in demand the chargers are
another team that needs corner picking
in the top 20
if they don't want to move up for an
offensive lineman or wide receiver
jc horn is the boomer bust prospect at
corner in this draft
but i'm gonna bet on because
his brand of football lepco gets flagged
a lot at the next level and i hate it
it's annoying that the league has become
this way in 1995
jc horn might be the third pick in the
draft but every time
you get grabby or play a little too
physical down the field
the refs throw that laundry over and
over again it's nonsense it's room to
the game to an extent it's ruined
defense
but i think him and greg newsom top 25
picks in this draft at corner
they're both guilty of it a lot and
that's something you have to get away
from at the next level
and it's very hard to coach out of guys
but i'm betting on him because he's such
a good athlete
he's so confident he just i love the way
he plays the game
i think he'll be okay but it is
something that everybody's gonna have
their concerns over and i'll give you
one bonus one here because
i'm kind of mad at myself that i gave
you two top 20 corners
let's go with elijah molden from
washington
small not fast but he just does
everything the right way
can play slot corner can play safety i
think he could survive on the outside in
the right matchups
he's got great instincts he's the best
tackling corner in the draft
he always knows how to recognize routes
always knows where to be
and loves to disrupted the catchpoint so
elijah molden
everybody's going to look at his profile
and go 5-9
you know four upper four fives four six
forty no thanks
some of the best corner film in this
trap gonna be a really good pro
uh connor rogers fan stole my brain
waves he said jc horn screams
new england at 15 if they don't move up
you talk about like
coaches that let their corners use their
hands belichick is like
keep doing it until they call it also
i'm a little bit selfish
but if somehow patrick certain went to
the dolphins at 18
and j.c horn went to the saints at 28.
i love the notion of seeing them play
where their fathers played
and if you do not know the story of how
joe horn
got to the nfl i beg you to look it up
joe horn was playing i believe in the
canadian football league
and had jerry rice's workout video
and watched it so much that he recreated
it
and that's how he got on an nfl roster
and for a few years
was a top five top 10 wide receiver in
the nfl
so you know with somebody like jc it is
baked into his brain
the work ethic that it will take to be
one of the best
at the next level love it app comment
here
where exactly in round one is morick
going to be drafted this is from
jablonski
i need to know who morig is connor
yeah here you go let go trayvon merrick
from tcu
maybe the best cover safety in the
entire draft really reminds me of justin
reed
who's had some nice years in houston but
reminds me of him coming out of stanford
where
you know you look at it i think with
mary he's somebody that
plays the ball really well can cover out
of the slot
and right now you're not seeing trayvon
mary but he's someone that
is perfect for this nfl era where you
need cover safeties guys that can play
too high
guys that could play single high guys
that can run with these
move tight ends out of the slot really
good ball production
a lot of confidence understands how to
play the vertical
passing game can flip his hips can go
sideline to sideline
really good range so trayvon marig i
mean even the raiders at 17 if you want
to talk early even the patriots at 15 do
i expect that to happen
no but i think he's going round one i
think even when you look at green bay
they could be a sleeper team for him
i just love the way he plays the game he
knows how to come downhill and play the
football
a fearless kind of player he's done it
all at safety that tcu secondary
has been very very impressive to watch
the last two years
and he's been one of the the staples of
it the guy on the back end that gets
everybody in line the guy in the back
end that
is the last line of defense but can come
to the line of scrimmage and cover so
marig is a name we're going to be
grading on night one
and it's been quiet around him because
we're obsessed with the wide receivers
and the quarterbacks but he's just a
rock-solid ten-year starter at the
safety position
six six foot two oh two four 4-5 i saw
last year we had
uh jeff gladney get drafted in the first
round out of tcu
uh trevin merrig will likely be added to
that list uh do you have another safety
for me
uh that could be even late first round
early second
yeah it's gonna be richie grant from ucf
probably looking in that second to third
round rage
arrange a little bit of the discount
version of
mary to an extent but richie grant has
incredible ball production i think he
had 10 career interceptions there
has played at a really really high level
at the senior bowl looked like the best
coverage player
on the field at times and is he the
biggest
guy in the world no but the range is so
good he reminds me of nasir atterly who
came out of the draft two years ago
from delaware went to the chargers
another player with really really good
range and
grant is somebody much like marig is
coming out of a secondary that
has made a lot of big plays him and
their corner aaron robinson
are gonna have their names called on
that night two of the draft tag
tag gallon who didn't play this year
opted out but the 2019 film is really
good is a nice day three corners so
ucf has done a really nice job
developing secondary players for the nfl
and richie grant just has the range and
the ball skills on the back end teams
that
rely on safeties in single high and can
recognize
things are just going to love this
player and
quite frankly you just don't get a lot
of safeties with that kind of range in
each draft you might get two to three in
each draft so
despite the size maybe not the fastest
guy but plays
fast on the field grant can make an
impact and can be a day one starter
andrew l magnuson friend of the the show
noted sticky fill in the blank richie
grant
is safety number blank
oh well let's pull it up and take a look
so i break it down into free safeties
and strong safeties he is free safety
number three
i have trayvon marie of course ahead of
him jamar johnson from indiana
ahead of him as well a late riser so
safety number three
uh free safety number three round two
player
and the strong safeties are more in that
round three kind of range so he's ahead
of all of them
uh date i know i see like dane brugler
has him at number one
so there's it's an interesting overall
how is this safety class
in your mind is it deep is it is it top
heavy what do you think
you can find what you need you're not
going to find
derwyn james you're not going to find
you know jamal adam
yeah exactly you're not going to find
these guys like that but
if you need guys that have range and
cover on the back end
mary johnson grant cisco javon holland
they could all do that if you need these
big match-up players that can play in
the box can run with tight ends
strong safeties you have nasal dean from
sfu you have divine diablo one of our
favorites of this show
you have jacoby stevens from lsu so
you know and stevens is kind of keanu
neil light in that extent
he's almost a linebacker in the box so
the safety class
is deep in an extent that there's niche
players for everything you could want
and we'll have a lot of safeties taken
in the top 106 picks
a lot of love for syracuse product andre
cisco and i love him simply because he
went to syracuse
you ready for rapid fire q a connor
rogers
let's do it man okay first one up sports
hernia
biggest surprise the top 15 what's it
gonna be
i don't think we're gonna get a ton of
surprises i think the question
is going to be how do the receivers go
and if people aren't prepared for it
jaylen waddle is probably going to go
earlier than you think and that's boring
because i've told you that from day one
but with waddle speed he's probably
going to go in the top ten and i think
there'll be a big group of draft fans or
college fans that go
over devonte smith maybe even over kyle
pitts i wouldn't be shocked
so i think jaylon waddle will be the
surprise
and then i just think the offensive line
run can get crazy it could start in the
top 15. vera tucker tevin jenkins those
guys could start real early so
i don't think it's going to be this
wildly eventful top 15 once we get
through the quarterbacks that go one
through
three but waddle is my surprise guy
next one up bama rader how do you feel
about garrett wallow from tcu being a
sleeper pick in this draft
he's a tackling machine right he's a
little undersized he might not be the
fastest guy but he's got good agility
where those things kind of translate to
special teams reminds me a little bit of
blake
cashman who you know came out and was
another undersized run and chase
linebacker with
great leadership really the the core of
the defense right the middle of the
defense that will play
bigger than that size and you see it
right there taking on an offensive line
a lead blocker he'll come downhill and
and be a thumper so i think wallow his
path to a long nfl career is you know
he's going to be a day three pick
he's going to be a long term special
teams kind of captain player
and a rotational sub package linebacker
but i like seeing names like that
mentioned on our show
this one comes from sad jet fan who is
the
dream jets draft sleeper that no one is
talking about
man i feel like we've talked about them
all at this point
i mean when you look at it the dream
sleeper
i don't know if there is one we've
talked a million times about quarterback
early we've talked about all the
offensive linemen
i guess the dream not sleeper and extent
for me though left go is round three i
would like to see them make a play for a
guy like kenny gainwell out of memphis
they need more juice at the running back
position
every single mock draft i don't know if
it's because it's easy for people
they go oh let's give them travis
etienne because they need a running back
and they
joe douglas i don't think it's his
identity his dna to take a running back
early
i think that extra seattle through a
grounder will be where they take running
back
and gainwell or michael carter would be
the dream fits for me
uh you've talked before about caleb
farley about his athleticism and his
injury history
this one comes from aj sandy is there a
chance caleb farley drops to pick
29 for the packers there is and i think
they're one of the teams that's most
equipped to take that kind of
risk a high profile athletic corner with
back injuries
anything could happen he could fall out
of the first round no matter what his
agent says and
i'm rooting for caleb farley i love the
film seems like a really confident guy
a guy that's really easy to root for i
just think the days of being a top 15
pick are behind us and if you're a team
in the top 20 that risk is
it's gigantic i think he's a great fit
in tennessee
you know in the top 25 picks of the
draft but tennessee is recovering from
getting
zero production from their round one
pick last year
can they take that chance in a different
mold not a character mold but a health
mold this year
love the fit so green bay i think it's
perfect
i just i think he does get there too but
is green bay gonna look at it and go
we need an impact player as the aaron
rodgers era comes to a close
if farley's healthy is that guy nobody
knows
if he will be healthy for a full 17 game
season
final one from the iceberg for the
ravens
at 20 oh two more so this one is from
joe kane for heisman
connor how far will landon dickerson
fall
not that far probably round two and the
only reason is because of medicals he's
got a long medical history going back to
florida state
transfers to alabama the best interior
offensive lineman that i have
watched in this draft cycle he his
interviews with coaching staffs have
been
off the charts people just love him left
go everyone i talk to
goes man how can i convince our staff to
take landon dickerson i don't care about
the medical history i'll take the risk
so landon dickerson is going to be a
round two player and if things
finally go right for him medically he
could be the
he could be a pro bowl player from year
one he's that good
okay keep it rolling rogue j-rogue
who do you see the chargers getting on
defense or will they go o-line to help
herbert out
the chargers are in a feel it out
process right now because they're in the
no man's land of the draft can
penesul drop a little bit maybe we make
the pl we know they've been aggressive
they have no problem coming up for
players
maybe they make a play to come up for
penny sewell or sean slater or maybe
you know a beer a tucker falls into
their lap or maybe they sit there and go
we didn't get the o-line we wanted let's
take jc horn
let's take greg newsom certain fell we
didn't expect it let's take certain we
need help at corner
the chargers are a very very
unpredictable team right now because
they are in such a strange part of the
draft where it starts to turn over from
blue chip players to
solid starter kind of players so i think
the chargers are one that you circle and
go
they don't need a quarterback but they
are definitely a trade-up candidate
okay bpa for the chargers let's go to
las vegas next in the rapid fire
i love this thank you for doing this
especially getting to know the hidden
jewels
what are your thoughts and what do you
hear in the direction of the raiders are
going to go from b-reel 24
well number one thank you i love hidden
jewels that's i like that better than
hidden gems at this point
your football team is one of the most
unpredictable drafters i have
ever encountered in my years of doing
this clelan farrell
early and this isn't me knocking them
because they've made some good decisions
as well
and also at times very predictable
everybody knew they were taking josh
jacobs but damon arnett is one that
you know i didn't expect that so i'm
sitting here and going well
the facts and the indisputable evidence
tells us
17 is the perfect spot for kevin jenkins
or whatever top offensive lineman falls
you have needs there
you have a quarterback that you need to
protect but do they go outside the box
again
that's always what i'm gonna wonder with
the raiders but
sitting here and go and i like mike
mayok i know it's trendy right now to
crush the raiders
john gruden makes a lot of decisions
there so let's not be quick to run mike
mayok out the door
i think they need a scale back a calm
draft
and just take a safe reliable offensive
lineman at 17.
i will always argue before we get to
this last one
that mike mayok's initial rankings were
always
wildly different than everybody saw
and after he began talking to more
people
around the league it got fine-tuned i
will never forget
when he had deshawn kaiser as his number
one
quarterback and then on draft day
he was suddenly number five and so i do
wonder
when you can talk to 32 teams to refine
your process
versus you got to keep it serious and to
yourself
that's when the damon arnett's and the
cleveland ferals
start to happen and so that's just my
theory
it's how i've always felt about mike
mayok i think he's a great listener
but it's hard to listen when you can't
talk to anybody okay
last one and that's a good edit great uh
that's a good edit going to sean kaiser
from number one to number five
so hopefully he learns from his mistakes
yeah i guess so okay
for the ravens at 27 would you take aziz
or away for the edge position i feel
like the ravens are most likely to trade
down
but if they don't who's your pick don't
forget matt
judon their number one pass rusher now
plays for the patriots
yeah a great question and i would take
aziz o'gilari because he's the way more
talented player
and a lot of times you look at this two
different players right away is much
bigger much
thicker more hand in the dirt the ravens
are one of the most
multiple front teams in the entire nfl
with wink martindale they will throw
everything out there they are not a team
you write 3-4 or 4-3
or or edge-in or anything like that they
are a team that
you'll see four different fronts per
game
so and a lot of stand-up outside rushers
and that's what aziz is aziz is
i can stand up sure i'm 245 pounds but
i'll put my hands in the chest of an
offensive tackle
come crashing down against guys pulling
great first step for an outside speed
rush
knows how to use his hands to create
violence very active hands
and can turn into the pocket and go for
the kill shot for strip sack so
away has no pass rush plan i love his
athleticism i love his hustle i love his
size
but i'm looking at this for baltimore
and saying get somebody
on the field that can wreak havoc right
away you just lost matt judah that's
okay
i'm not panicking i think matt giudan's
a solid player but he's not
this game-changing top three pass rusher
on the outside
ogilari can come in and give you enough
from day one where away you just don't
know
uh i kind of equate it in basketball to
when a
ball handler has a bag and they have a
lot of moves in the bag
and if you haven't had any some coaches
are going to look at it and go
oh we can add some but why not have a
guy that already has them
and take those to the next level uh that
was our final live show guys
thank you so much for joining us these
last seven weeks they have legitimately
flown by i cannot believe it
we are not done though sunday 11 a.m in
the br app and be
our youtube we are going to have a mock
draft where conor is going to make the
pick
for every team in the first round if you
can't watch it with us sunday at 11 a.m
it will be on demand all throughout the
week
that you can watch it whenever go to
your team scrub through the timeline
and see who your team is taking
draftknight
akib to leap rg3 reggie wayne
cam jordan connor rogers hair my
sweaters
it's going to be a very big night we
unlike espn and nfl network
if the news breaks on twitter we're not
going to wait
we're going to do it right then so as
you're waiting for espn to get through
their
feature story about how this draft pick
didn't know how to read
we are gonna be breaking down and not
that that's a bad thing
we're gonna be breaking down the next
pick oh they're in commercial
we already are talking about jc horn we
don't have time
it's a big night we're not waiting for
anybody this is br we do it different
okay uh so day three it will be connor
rogers taylor rooks has taken over my
spot
i need to fly to new york and have a
wedding shower
which is apparently thing people do i
don't know i got roped into that one
connor i'm trying to get out of it
special guest though will be joining you
on sundays and as
always post video reactions to your
team's draft picks posted in the nfl
draft community
and we will be sending you some swag
anything you want to say before we go
kahn
dude i cannot wait this draft show this
year is going to be
we use that extra time right we don't
have commercials
and we don't like you said we don't
waste time on these extra stories and
features and all these things where
you're going to hear more about your
team
and the players that your team is
drafting than anywhere else and you're
not just going to hear it from me
you're here from a keep to leave grading
every pick like we said rg3
reggie wayne cam jordan dude i can't
wait it's gonna be a blast
as somebody that has watched the giraffe
for a long time
there is nothing worse than your team is
on the clock
and they're interviewing trevor lawrence
and all you want to hear about is what
is your team going to do
we promise you that ain't happening for
connor rogers i'm adam lefkow thanks for
watching we'll see you sunday for the
mock draft show
peace
so
[Music]
you